jason whitton out of the nfl again he's
going to sign a one-day contract with
the dallas cowboys so he can officially
retire as a member of the team he spent
what a year with the cowboys after he
unretired and then a year with the
raiders i can't believe it's already
been
three seasons ago that he was on monday
night football i can't it seems like it
was it was not all that long ago but
when you think about that monday night
football booth it seems like it goes
through a significant overhaul every
year
and i texted him a few minutes ago and
said i look forward to presenting you
for the hall of fame in five years i
don't know if he'll be a first thought
hall of famer or not it'll be an
interesting discussion but you know he
obviously has hall of fame numbers and
had a hall of fame career was a lot of
fun uh getting to watch him play uh
through the course of of his
uh career and getting to know him a lot
he's he's a great guy i think he's gonna
go into coaching this time i'm gonna be
surprised if he doesn't end up as a
coach probably start out as assistant
tight ends coach somewhere maybe a tight
end coach who knows i know the raiders
were looking at one point i don't know
if they filled that job or not but i
would look for him mike to go into
coaching and obviously not the tv booth
this time
if and when he gets to the hall of fame
a very important question who decides
whether the bust is bald or has the
toupee on it
well he would get to decide that i think
he gives him a picture and then they do
it based on the picture in a sit-down
but if he's bald and wants it with hair
you have to go off the picture obviously
yeah or or you could you could
put an actual toupee on top of the bust
for special occasions like hall of fame
weekend put the toupee on the rest of
the year take the two payoffs then
you've got flexibility forever
permanently you have the opportunity to
change up your look if you are the jason
whitton bronze bust hanging out in the
hall of bus talking to each other as
john madden says when the lights go off
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports